من جحيم بخموت وصل ايغوردي من مجموعه من
النازحين الى الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها
السلطات المواليه لروسيا
حاملين معهم ما استطاعوا خرج الالاف من
سكان المدينه التي تشهد اعنف المعارك في
رحله لم يكتب لكثيرين خلالها النجاه
كل ما بقي لدي من اوراق هو هويتي كل شيء
احترق مع بيتي ساعدته القوات الروسيه
لمغادره حي الينوفاكا في بخموت وكنا نموت
تحت القصف عائله غادرت قبلي في اتجاه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه انوي العوده الى مدينه
حينما تتيح لي اضرف ذلك
توفر السلطات المواليه لروسيا في مدينه
شختيورز الشرقيه دنيتك الرعايه الطبيه
والطعام والاقامه المؤقته لنحو 1200 نازح
من بخموت قبل توزيعهم على مقاطعات روسيه
اخرى
خيار يبقى ملائما لكثير من هؤلاء بعد قسوه
ما عاشوه طوال سته اشهر من المعارك في
المدينه
ضميرها منزلي بالكامل انتقلت وعائلتي منذ
الصيف الماضي الى مدرسه شرقيبه كانت مكتظه
بلا كهرباء ولا ماء ولا تدفئه عشنا ظروفها
قاسيه وشرفنا على الموت لولا ما قدمه لنا
حينها متطوعون انه جحيم احاول ان لا اتذكر
تساهم منظمات محليه ودوليه في حمله تقديم
العون للنازحين من مناطق بخموت وسوليدار
نحو منطقه دانيتك في ظل الوضع الانساني
صعب الذي يواجه من نزح من سكان باخموت في
الاتجاهين تقدر مصادر الروسيه ان نحو 4000
مدني مازال داخل المدينه ويصعب اجلاء
معظمهم بسبب تواصل المعارك
الماساه ذاتها اذا مع اختلاف الزمان
والمكان من ماريوبول الى ليسي تشانس
وسوليدار وصولا الى بخمه التي لا يبدو
انها ستكون اخر الفصول
هذه المناطق البعيده نسبيا عن خطوط التماس
ان تتزايد اعداد النازحين اليها
وضع يفاقم الازمه الانسانيه مع احتدام
المعارك وتوسع رقعتها الجغرافيه